well what are the most intriguing world
championship matches of all time was
between Veera manchak and Sonia graph
and this is one that really could be
made into a movie and I know Jen this is
one of your favorite topics to talk
about well absolutely because the thing
about chess and particularly this
Women's World Championship in 1939 is
the way that chess intersects with the
history of the world and no more time is
that statement more apt than the 1939
Olympiad held in Buenos Aires in
Argentina and this was both an Olympiad
for the open and also a Women's World
Championship but it wasn't a match it
was more like an open tournament and the
best woman would win so there was very
men chick who was already a seven-time
Women's World Champion
so she was coming in as a heavy favorite
they set sail from Europe in July of
1939 having no idea of course that they
would not be coming back some of them
the war was about to break out in Europe
that's right so the tournaments began in
August in Buenos Aires and actually in
the case of Sonja Graf who was living in
Germany at the time she was told by
Goebbels the minister of Nazi propaganda
that she could not play for Germany
because she was so vocal against the
Nazi regime
she got stripped of her flag and had to
play under the flag of Liberty she ended
up getting second in the tournament
second to Vera min-shik who just got 18
out of 20 points completely crushed the
field well and she was winning in her
individual game against Vera so she was
ever so close to becoming the Women's
World Champion and I always think of
that as a bit sad because Sonia was such
an incredible figure when it comes to
her character and you know she was an
author bon vivant
one of the people who really showed how
chess could leave you this life of
adventure right um but she didn't win
the championship very men chick did the
very sad thing about very many she did
go back to Europe
unlike Sonja Graf unlike Knight orphe
and she died in the London Blitz in 1944
one of them bombings exactly but Sonja
knew that you know after Goebbels said
that about
was pretty clear this yeah she wasn't
going anywhere gonna survive so she
stayed in Argentina ended of immigrating
into the United States and actually won
a couple of US women's championships
right another player who also ended up
staying in Argentina who's very well
known to audiences is McCollum my
daughter
absolutely well in fact the entire
polish team I said we're not going to go
back to Poland and they all stayed as
did many many other European players
saying look you know the outbreak of war
in Europe it's just not safe and their
allotment mostly Jewish there's no
question about it and if you stop and
think about it how the heck are you
supposed to get back to Europe anyway I
mean it's not like you're just gonna
catch an international jet flight you're
gonna take a ship and how do you know
the ship's not gonna get blown up all
the bombings that were going on
absolutely the relevance of that also to
the World Championships because you have
Alekhine who's sitting there waiting for
a challenger but nothing can be done
absolutely we can't play there's war
going on sure so he sits and he sits and
he's depressed and he's waiting around
for a challenger all those years while
the war is going on exactly and at the
very end when the war finally stops he
gets a bid that says he's gonna be chat
he can finally play again and then he
dies in his hotel room exactly and so
the war had such an impact on chess and
the history of the World Chess
Championship and not just the men's as
you mentioned with Alekhine but also the
ladies so in the case the vote we know
what they did to solve the World
Championship now we have a vacant title
what did they do in the case of the
ladies it wasn't always match play it
was tournament place did they just
continue the tournament well the next
world Women's World Championship if I
recall correctly was be cold and rude
anko those are Soviet at the time now
yes but with with verum in check dying
in 1944 I mean what a tremendous loss
for the chess world you know very men
Sheikh was way ahead of her time she was
the first woman that would play against
the top men of her day yeah and in fact
there was famously a very mentok Club
that's right which was supposed to be
for men who there was a very elite group
of names in that club wasn't there
exactly
that you wanted to join but they almost
took if you like there's a lot of a
camaraderie yes she was a really nice
person and it's just devastating to see
about we really got even more from these
players you know more stories more games
and I think that's what's so amazing
about chess history how it's an art that
we can look at the games and it also
intersects with history itself and for
children especially that can you know
teach you about these words World War
two had a massive impact in the chess
world but particularly in woman's chest
killing this grand figure of chess who
was the first woman to compete on the
equal terms with men way ahead of her
time not only did you do
really the Judith Polgara of the world
and that exact moment also of course
you've mentioned the loss of alexander
alekhine but there were many
grandmasters they simply died by hunger
or disease starvation I mean these two
world wars devastated Europe in
devastated the chess world indeed and it
led to a rethink of how the World
Championships would be run from that
moment on the events of fidei taking
over as an international body and the
age really of the private World
Championships ended right there with the
war closed a very important point in
chess history